okay thank you um so i'm going to be
talking about actually three topics that
are relevant to this group
so after hearing people's talks i
thought i would squeeze as much in as i
could and apologies in advance but i
will be speaking quickly
okay so phylogenomics which is basically
the combination of phylogeny and genome
scale data that's the context here and i
just want to point out that you can see
that in this uh
this
phylogenetic quote-unquote tree it's not
even a tree there are these horizontal
gene transfers so when we're talking
about phylogenetics we're going beyond
just looking for phylogenetic trees
we're also going to be interested
in recovering where their lateral gene
transfers
so a phylogenomics pipeline is actually
pretty complex it starts with thinking
about what data you're going to want to
look at figuring out orthology
potentially doing multiple sequence
alignments on each locus
getting gene alignments and gene trees
either then concatenating the alignments
to get the tree or using the gene trees
to get the species tree or doing a
network
and then looking at branch support
estimating dates and trying to use this
to look at biology and the issue is that
everything you're doing up here
affects this
what happens with your final outcome
depends upon what you did earlier so
there's the there's a real consequence
to accuracy based upon how you handle
those
estimation problems
so i've worked on several international
consortia
trying to get phylogenies for the large
datasets with the planned transcriptome
project the problems were very large
multi-copy gene families which meant
very large multiple sequence lymans
and we decided in the end not to even
look at the multi-copy genes which meant
that we lost a lot of our data and then
we get a species tree from this but then
we see that the gene trees are very
different from each other and it's
consistent with incomplete lineage
sorting
similar thing with the avian project
except that there wasn't as much gdl so
we didn't lose really that much data
but we still had a lot of gene tree
heterogeneity consistent with incomplete
lineage sorting
so
these are problems that affect
many phylogenomics pipelines and today
i'm going to focus on these two
questions how do you do multiple
sequence alignments okay
this is something that's relevant to
pairwise alignment but it's more complex
how do you get good gene trees
how do you use these alignments and
trees to get species trees
and i'm going to be talking about how to
do that by combining gene trees
so three topics
but i want to point out that everything
i'm going to be talking about is really
kind of a statistical estimation problem
because in all of these problems you
basically pose
a mathematical model of evolution
whether that's only substitutions or has
insertions and deletions
that's that depends but you also have
how genes are evolving inside a species
tree
different kinds of evolutionary
processes the estimation of the
alignments and the trees is a
statistical estimation problem
so
large datasets are difficult from very
interesting reasons one is just size
you can have many loci
you can have many species
you could have many individuals in each
of your species
you could have missing data you get a
heterogeneity if you're allowing
yourself to look at genome scale data
you don't get nice data anymore it's not
like every gene has lots of signal
there's going to be difficulties
so the larger your data set the more
complex the more heterogeneous
and many of the analytical pipelines are
using likelihood-based calculations
whether maximum likelihood or bayesian
and this means they have numerics issues
they have runtime issues they have
memory issues but they also depend upon
the model if the model is a problem then
maybe everything is a problem
so these are sort of the context
so today i'm going to try to talk about
three different things
getting species trees from gene trees
that was actually what i said i would
talk about but probably most of you here
are not actually trying to get species
trees so you might be interested in some
of the other questions more so
next one is how to get very large
maximum likelihood trees
and here but i mean is many many leaves
in your tree
maximum likelihood on really large
datasets is really not adequately solved
so i'm going to talk about what we're
doing to try to make it more feasible
and finally i'm going to start with
something on multiple sequence limit
where i have a conundrum
so i have really good results to tell
you about how to get species trees i
have new work on how to get large
maximum likelihood trees and i have a
problem about multiple sequence
alignment so i'm going to end with the
problem because that's probably the most
interesting thing
okay so species trees
so we have you know here we have four
species but even these four species
human chimp grill and orangutan are not
that easy getting the true tree on just
these four species is complicated and
it's complicated for multiple reasons
even if the only thing you want is the
unrooted tree
we're going to be talking about getting
unrooted trees rather than rooted trees
because evolution is basically time
reversible
so
statistical consistency a very basic
concept
says that in a statistical estimation
problem
if you can prove that your method will
converge to the correct answer with
probability going to one as your data
goes to infinity it's a statistically
consistent estimator
so we want to know if our species tree
methods are statistically consistent
so what's going to infinity perhaps is
the length of the genome
so
length of the gm goes to infinity can we
prove that error will go to zero
the problem is
that there are all these causes for
heterogeneity across the genome
incomplete lineage sorting is a
population level process it happens all
over as i showed you it happened with
the plant dataset the avian dataset
every paper you read
estimation is about
to show you this
there's also gene duplication and loss
there's also horizontal gene transfer
and when you have
any of these you have species trees and
gene trees being different here's an
example just a human chimp gorilla an
orangutan human and chimp sibling here
that looks right
human and gorilla sibling here that
looks wrong but it's not wrong it's
correct for the gene it's just not
correct for the species tree you get
different gene trees than the species
tree
so
there's this model where the species
tree generates genes
the gene trees can differ from the
species tree the gene trees evolve
sequences
and you get sequences at the bottom what
do you do with the sequences at the
bottom if you're a standard biologist
you just do concatenation you take all
the alignments for all the genes you put
them into one matrix and you run your
favorite method maximum likelihood
distance based whatever
concatenation using maximum likelihood
ml in phylogeny does not refer to
machine learning it refers to maximum
likelihood
so that's
hierarchical model
but if you do that standard
concatenation approach there's a there
are two theorems that have been proven
that show that it can be inconsistent
and positively misleading converge to
the wrong tree with probability going to
one and that the two theorems depend
upon whether it's partitioned or
unpartitioned maximum likelihood so it
can give you the wrong answer
with probability going to one theorem
but in practice you sort of get this
kind of thing as data increases or goes
down and then it sort of stays low
it doesn't go to zero but it's not high
that's a typical thing in practice
okay
so but let's go back to this model since
we know we have a hierarchical model how
about just invert it as an estimation
method
if you invert it the first thing you're
going to do is take the alignments
assuming you know the alignments which
of course is a big assumption but take
the alignments
estimate gene trees take the gene trees
and estimate the species tree makes
sense right each of them is under a
different model so you can do this
so you can do model based inference of
gene trees
model based inference of the species
tree to do the model based inference of
the species tree you need to have some
idea about what is the model for how
gene trees are different from the
species tree but this is well
established for incomplete lineage
sorting
so
almond and degenerate rhodes did this
beautiful theorem that said under the
multi-species coalescent
if you only have four species
the most frequently observed gene tree
is the species tree with probability
going to one
so if you only have poor species you
don't have to worry about it
just look at all the gene trees you have
on those four species whichever one
appears the most often these are
unrooted gene trees whichever one
appears most often that's it
so that gives you an estimation method
for four species
but to do more than four species you're
just combining estimates on quartet
trees they also proved perhaps in
another paper that it's not true for
five species because there's something
called the anomaly zone but it's okay
for four okay so astral is now a method
that takes advantage of that quartet
theorem there are other methods that
also take advantage of the quartet
theorem but astral is the one that has
dominated
the uh the usage now
and the idea is it's taking the gene
trees
which are the script t
all your gene trees and it's finding the
species tree that maximizes the cortex
support from the gene trees really just
looking at induced quartet trees
this is an nb heart optimization problem
astral is not solving the optimization
problem but what it is doing is
solving a constrained version of the
problem
so what it does is it says i'm going to
find the optimal solution to this
np-card optimization problem
within a constrained search space it
defines the constrained search space
from the input gene trees it does that
in a way that maintains statistical
consistency and becomes polynomial time
and the result is that it's low degree
polynomial time
so the set of allowed by partitions is x
the runtime is quadratic at worst in x
times the input size
so low degree polynomial time
it's used all over the place this is
just a sample from many years ago
this is the important comparison
this is an analysis on simulated data
that erin mulley my former student did
only 26 species but a thousand genes
and what you see is different methods
astralis in blue
concatenation using maximum likelihood
with rxml is in purple
this is the left the rightmost one this
is astral this is error
so low amounts of ils high amounts of
ils
very high amounts of ils
if you compare the methods across the
different conditions you'll also see
m g mean g t e e g t e is gene tree
estimation error if you have true gene
trees you have no problem if you have
estimated gene trees you can have more
error
but i just want you to see some examples
under
low ils
there's really no reason to not do
concatenation
concatenation purple at the extreme
right is always the best
you don't have much ils you don't need
to do anything special
with high
ils there's now an advantage to using
one of these methods
astral astrid and mps three different
methods that combine gene trees
but when you get to high gene tree
estimation error over here
even with
high ils you might prefer concatenation
and then when you have very high ils
there's actually more reason to do these
astral and other methods than
concatenation
until you get to high gnt estimation
error so this is really interesting
raxaml is better than these other
methods
even though there's no theorem of
statistical consistency
even under very high ils where the
anomaly zone is going on so there is
this issue about if you're going to
choose a method it depends upon the data
there's no theorem that can guide you
okay it depends upon the data
okay
summary of the lessons from ils based
species transformation
for every four species the most probable
unrooted gene tree is the species tree
astral takes advantage of that in a
computationally efficient way by
constraining the search space but
concatenation can be
a competitive method it can be more
accurate
those are the lessons about ils
but what about gene duplication and loss
so we got rid of a lot of data with the
thousand plant transcriptome project
gene family trees are what you get
when you have gene duplication and loss
if you don't limit yourself to
orthologous genes you get these genes
that are multi-coffee
so you get a tree something like this
the true species tree has just three
species a b and c but there's a
duplication up here so here's the gene
family tree
you can see that there's two copies of a
two copies of b and two copies of c
if that's your input how do you work
with it
so
options you throw out your multi-copy
genes that's what we did with the 1kp
project
you figure out orthology that is not
easy it is not solved
or you figure out a way to use your
gene family trees without knowing
orthology and this is what i'm going to
tell you about this
but nothing was proven statistically
consistent until 2019 this is pretty
recent
what happened in
2019 is that
sebastian rock and his student
and
proved
in a paper that we wrote together that
the most probable quartetry
under gdl is still the species tree same
theorem as for ils and therefore
a version of astral that have been
designed to deal with multiple alleles
actually could be used in this context
it's called astral multi and it would be
statistically consistent
that was the first proof
but then erin molloy did an analysis
comparing
astral multi here it just says astral
but it's astral multi this is error this
is runtime astral multi to other methods
the only method that it's better than
reliably is
dupetree which is like a parsimony style
thing minimizing duplications
these other methods are not in fact
provably statistically consistent but
they're more accurate
molar f and fast small rps more accurate
than astral multi under all of these
settings so here we have a statistically
consistent method that's not as good as
something that we don't know if it's
statistically consistent that's a
general trend in phylogeny okay
statistical consistency says nothing
about performance on finite data it
gives you confidence about if you have
enough data nothing about what happens
with finite data
okay so what was nice is that that
result about astral multi being
statistically consistent gaziavis mirab
who is the main developer of astral to
make a version of astral
that was specifically designed for
dealing with gdl
so the idea here is that it takes every
multi-copy gene family tree
and it roots the gene family tree and it
tries to figure out where the
duplications occur and after it's done
that it then sort of modifies the
quartet optimization approach
to come up with a method that's still
polynomial time
okay so
there's a theorem that says if it
correctly roots
and tags each gene family tree it's
consistent
but effectively that's the same as
knowing orthology but that's the only
theoretical guarantee
what we saw is that astral multi
is not it is actually worse than astral
pro okay
astro pro is more accurate than astral
multi it's not even it's right here
they're very close but astral pro is
better faster molar fest is worse
but run time wise astral pro is pretty
good not quite as good as astral multi
so here you have it a method that's
actually practically useful
it might
be statistically consistent even with
errors but we don't have a proof
okay
uh two key ideas for remember this is
from what i showed you before the two
key ideas from ils
the idea that every four species the
most probable gene tree is identical to
the tree on the true species tree and
that asheville can find solutions using
this constrained optimization
it's the same thing for ils plus gdl
same thing the most probable unrooted
gene tree is topologically identical to
the true species tree even when you have
ils and gdl together
and the same algorithmic approach can
work but for statistical consistency and
astral pro
although it's not guaranteed
statistically consistent it has this
additional step rooting and tagging gene
trees okay
so
what about hgt
there's actually other theorems by
sebastian rock and siggy sneer
that show that the most probable
quartetry is equal to the species tree
here
so if you think about lots of hgt but
there's still an underlying species tree
can you get the underlying species tree
they proved that that was possible with
cartetries with random http but bounded
amounts
ziggy sneer and and sebastian rock
so we actually did a simulation and
explored this and we saw that
quartet-based methods like astral were
more accurate than
than concatenation so we got this thing
over and over again quartet methods
can give you good results it's not true
under every model of gene feed
discordance but under multiple models
okay so idea you take gene trees you get
species trees
you do it with quartet trees
protect based tree estimation can give
you very good results not mentioned here
it's much faster than concatenation
you can replace the 250 cpu years that
we did for the avian tree
250 cpu years for a concatenation
analysis was something that just takes
perhaps minutes
there's really a big difference in
runtime
okay
part two i'm gonna zip through part two
and part three
all of this you know avian was 48
species the 1kp was like 100 species
what happens if you want to get a tree
on a million species
we have heard that there are many many
species of on earth how do we get trees
that are really on hundreds of thousands
of species okay
um
again we're getting unrooted trees
there are these models of sequence
evolution you can see there is no indels
here it's just substitutions
there are sequence evolution models such
as juke scanner the generalized tree
generalized
time reversible model gtr there's many
models of substitutions for sequences
evolving down trees
they're all have more or less the same
flavor iid across the sites
you have something going on here you
just describe it with some parameters
maximum likelihood is very very popular
and provably statistically consistent
under the nice models nice models and
ones that are iid
okay
i'm going to talk about results with
maximum likelihood
because that's what people do with their
data sets that are big the ones who have
the time can do bayesian
uh in theory consistent
low sample complexity
and empirically you get really good
results even with heuristics you're not
probably solving your problems you're
writing heuristics rexomil is the
standard one but raximil is not designed
for very large trees
so we came up with a technique that's
divide and conquer that allows you to
take a large data set divide it into
disjoint sets get trees on the disjoint
sets and then merge the trees it's not a
super tree method because these are
disjoint
and
by putting raximil on the subsets
you can actually take the advantage of
raxiom's accuracy but limitation to
small trees
so here are results that we published on
data sets that range from
a thousand sequences to fifty thousand
sequences
this is tree error
so rapsomel is here in red
this is iq tree here's sorry this is
fast tree iq tree raximil and here's our
divide and conquer technique
and what you can see is
fast tree is terrible here
rock smells the best this is a little
bit worse they're all about the same
fast tree is bad these are the same
fast tree is actually not bad raximil is
worse
our divide and conquer is better and
here we can only run fast tree and our
divide and conquer technique
so focusing just on the data sets where
you know the really large jsons with ten
thousand and fifty thousand
you can see that we can get trees
that rocks milk cannot even analyze
so this is a very recent work that we're
still trying to explore so if you have
very large trees you want to get max
molecular trees this is something you
can
try but you can use this with any kind
of tree estimator not just raximile
you can use it with species trees it
actually improves accuracy and reduces
run time
so it's a general purpose divide and
conquer technique for large trees
large in this case is the number of
leaves in the tree
okay
my last part which is where i want to
leave you with the conundrum
multiple sequence alignment you can't do
anything here without a multiple
sequence alignment
how do you get a good multiple sequence
alignment
so now multiple sequence limit is
actually one of these really big grand
challenges that has applications in many
areas
there's hard optimization problems but
the current many methods that are very
good just don't scale the large datasets
um by the way cato spoke
two days ago and he's the developer of
math which is really like
the best off-the-shelf software for
multiple sequence alignment but it
doesn't really scale well to large
datasets
alignment is actually recovering history
that's evolutionary
if you have a sequence that evolves into
another sequence with insertions and
deletions and substitutions
you can line them up
so this stuff got deleted so this stuff
is above dashes this t changes into a c
so the t is above a c
this
t was inserted so it's below a dash
pairwise alignment is a reflection of
evolutionary history multiple sequence
alignment is the same thing just with
transitivity
so you have this thing the true pairwise
alignment is recovering the evolutionary
history
what makes alignments difficult large
numbers of sequences high rates of
substitutions high rates of insertions
and deletions
very long sequences and sequence length
heterogeneity that can be the result of
evolution or of technology like if
you're including reads into your data
set
so
we did a study this is back from 2009
comparing different alignment methods
with raxaml
when you do a simulation you know the
truth
so you can compare the true alignment to
the estimate alignment the true tree to
the estimated tree
this is all these data sets have a
thousand sequences 15 different models
the top is tree error the bottom is
alignment error as you go from left to
right it's more or less sorted so you
can see errors increasing what's really
happening as you go from left to right
is that to some extent the the amount of
evolution is going up
substitutions are going up indels are
going up but there's different lengths
for the indels
so what happens as you go from left to
right is
maximum the true alignment is in black
so there's
tree error is low here then it goes up a
little bit
and it doesn't matter how you align the
data sets for the first six models
because you get the same tree error
but there is difference in the alignment
error
and then as you go to higher rates of
evolution triage goes up just because of
the rate of evolution but if you have to
estimate the alignment
error goes up for the alignment as well
and the one thing to notice is that
clustol which is like the most commonly
used alignment method has the worst
accuracy on large evolutionary distances
okay so what's going on here is that
some data sets with a thousand sequences
are easy
some are hard what matters is the
evolutionary diameter
so this suggests a divide and conquer
strategy take your data set divide into
subsets that are lower diameter get
alignments on the subsets merge the
alignments
when you've done that you can get a new
tree
and then you could iterate
and if you iterate each iteration might
improve the alignment therefore improve
the tree
so we studied that in 2009 with this
method called sate here's the result of
a 24-hour analysis with satay
better alignments better trees that led
to other developments of the same lot
type of thing
iteration with divide and conquer
and the last iterate the last methods of
this sort can go to a million sequences
with very high accuracy so basically if
you have a large data set you don't have
to give up multiple sequence alignment
you just have to use something that's
not off the shelf
one could say pasta is off the shelf but
pasta you know it's been around for a
long time magus is now better than pasta
and it's using math on subsets
math lindsay is great but it doesn't go
to large data sets
okay
statistical alignment
valified by ben redlings and mark
suchard
was a co-estimation method for
statistical alignment
it's uh the main method for this problem
this limit is the small data sets
and small meaning they suggest nothing
more than a hundred
um here's a simulation on proteins
only to at most
26
sequences
each balify analysis took two months of
run time
the others take a few minutes
what you're looking at here is mollers
for an sp score this is essentially
precision this is recall the closer you
are to the top corner the better this is
low rate of evolution of indulge
this is um and these are substitutions
and indels this is the hardest condition
this is the easiest condition
the red dot
is the one that's closest to the best
on simulated data
it's the best okay
valify is the best except
different story on biological data
these are different protein structural
benchmarks
same data set sizes
and what you can see is
the red dot is no longer at the top
now we this is the recall this is
precision
it's just not great
so this is where i'm leaving you with
the conundrum
i don't know what's going on i don't
know why we're seeing this
every time i ask someone what they think
is going on they give me a different
answer
but
three possible explanations
model miss specification i.e the balify
model is just not biologically realistic
for proteins
another one is that structural
alignments which is what the benchmarks
are are actually very different from
evolution i don't think they're so
different that they would explain
everything
and then the other one is the structural
benchmark alignments are simply not
correct even as structural alignments
that's possible
but depends on who you ask they have a
different answer so this is my question
right
and the reason i think this is important
is that if this is the problem
model misspecification
then what aspect of the model is wrong
and that will impact what we do in
everything
and if it's just that the benchmarks are
wrong okay fine that's not so worrisome
to me
okay and with this i want to thank you
for your attention
one question
thank you for that uh teddy i'd like to
ask you about your your last slide um
and the three uh points you raised i
sort of have a
interest in in hoping that it's number
one but i'm actually going to ask about
your comment about number two um you
said that you thought you could see
structural alignments and evolutionary
alignments being different but you
didn't think that would explain
everything i wondered if you could
elaborate on that okay so the point is
we know that structural alignments can
be different from evolution because you
can have parallel evolution you can have
convergent evolution to have certain
structures
does it happen so frequently
that you'd get this kind of really
significant difference that's the
question not does it happen but does it
happen so much that it would explain
that
right
so of course there's some people who
would say it does happen but it doesn't
happen enough to explain it other people
would say this is the major explanation
so every i should didn't we have this
conversation didn't i already ask you
what what's your answer
well i mean i i think that you know when
you get recurrent insertions and
deletions in loop regions in in proteins
then if you do a structural alignment
it'll look like they're in the sim you
know these these residues are so you
think that that would be explaining all
of these
every single benchmark here
i mean i think it'll give you distorted
estimates of you know endel rates and
over alignment in region loop regions
and proteins i don't know if it's enough
to explain audio okay well i think the
thing to realize here is what balify is
doing is uh
it's under aligning
so the structural benchmarks look over
aligned relative right but the over
alignment could be a could be a problem
about the structural alignments
it could be it could be more
this one
because the structural alignments are
done by humans
not just by structures right and this is
where nick goldman says they always like
to see things lining up exactly so
that's not quite the same thing as
structural limits and evolutionary
alignments being different it's more
that humans want things to be
lining up
okay anyway as you can see there is this
conundrum i don't know the answer
and i'd love to have people tell me over
the coffee break what they think is
going on that's it right okay thank you
very much